some people are just don't know how to
raise a kid you and then how complex it
is to raise a kid that's adopted that's
a different race than you y bro good
[__] luck that's hard she white no
the kid black you see okay you see that
okay I think that's a I think that's a
factor I think that's
[Music]
a do you guys remember the Nintendo
switch
Juggernaut no what's that it's that kid
he was 17 they took Nintendo switch at
oh yeah he just like bum rushed the
teacher he up he was like a big ass kid
right so the full story of that is now
laid out yeah um and his mom speaking
out against the two and there's not only
her but also a bunch of activists are
asking for him to be freed what happened
the woman who got demolished though is
asking for him to get the maximum
penalty which would be 30 years wow wow
so on each side you have two totally
opposite extremes of wait activists want
them to be freed a lot of them here
here's a video of it happening the video
is brutal next to his mom talking about
how it's not his fault is this the one
where um like a marine was there too is
it that one no I don't I don't know oh
this is his mom so here's the yeah his
mom adopted adoptive mom yeah for what
my son did and um nobody nobody should
ever have to go through that
but at the same time please consider
that my son has had a hard life and he's
gone through so much trauma in his life
he has
autism please show Mercy to him it's
devastating interesting right I mean oh
yeah so she's saying that nobody should
ever go through what that teacher went
through but consider that her son has
autism and has a traumatic it sounded
like she was saying no one went through
what my son has went not with the no
it's not that s like that though no one
has ever unleashed the beating the way
my son gave it power that's what it
sound he's an excellent fighter he's
considered the Guinness World Record he
set so uh here let me give you guys the
complete exact story about what went
down because back when we first covered
this nobody really knew exact they just
had the video and people made their
assumptions but here's exactly and then
we will play jury how it goes yeah and
then we'll decide who's right I kind of
feel like my assumptions are the same
still let's see let's see it's
interesting okay so here's here's how it
happens so um oh okay so they're
claiming first of all that Brendan
that's the name of the of the
17-year-old at the time who's now 18
that he's autistic so at the time of the
attack he was 17 years old uh standing
at a height of 66 weighing 270 he's a
big [__] so at a super young age less
than a year I believe he was adopted by
that woman and he was mostly
homeschooled all the way up till uh when
when he grew up but throughout his life
he always had rage issues can we also
replace his name replace Brendan with
super heavyweight fighter and then
replace the mom ending at 66 replace the
mom with Sandra Bullock oh wow okay this
[__] is bigger than Francis and
G dude he's a he's a super heavyweight
so he's always had rage issues and
required special needs care uh it got so
bad that the mom had to like send him to
a group home to live and at the group
home they specialized more in like the
type of education that he needs and they
make decisions for him so that's how he
ended up in public school the mom never
wanted to send him to public school but
the group home said it was okay and they
deemed him safe to go to public school
he would just have to go to special
needs classes I think in between other
classes is it because he whooped
everyone's ass at the group home and
like we need to set the honestly
honestly I wouldn't put it past them it
could be that but uh so she didn't agree
with that they did it anyway in his
special needs courses they would often
incentivize him to work by giving him
play time on his Nintendo switch so they
used that as a way to like get him to do
his stuff because otherwise it was
really difficult yeah uh they did say
that that's a system that he's used to
and if you were to take it away from him
you would have to do it really carefully
or at a specific point of time what
happened was that there's this uh
teacher's aid her name's n ditch and
she's the one who got beat up but
basically she's walking Brandon to his
next class so this is after his special
needs class he gets walked to the next
class where he starts taking out the
Nintendo switch and distracting other
students nit is like hey you got to put
it away you got to put it away so he
puts it away he just keeps taking it out
and then you know keeps getting asked to
put it away he just can't you know he
can't not play with it because it's a
Nintendo switch and you're in school
anyone would do that autism or not I
would do that um so then she texts after
the class she texts the teacher of that
class and says hey um next time he
shouldn't bring the switch to his uh
non-sp special needs class like in his
special needs class where that's part of
the how they incentivize him fine but at
the other class he probably shouldn't do
that what happens is he finds out that
she ratted on him and that's why he beat
her up we thought that she took it away
she never took it away he finds out that
that she texted the other teacher about
it and then he starts yelling at her
calls her a [__] a [__] spits in her
face I mean rats suck now I'm on his
side I'm on his side now so then I don't
[__] with no rats stitches get stitches
is the same snitches so no snitching
dude so when she turns for the door in
the middle of all of that that's when he
shoves her down and then beats her to a
pulp knocks her out I think she had like
six broken ribs and like all this like
stuff she has all these like uh she
claims that now she's got some like
issues with you know with her brain and
stuff yeah probably like
issues you see how [__] out she was
she was [__] out but did she learn
her lesson did they ask her she's like
I'm sorry no actually she's pissed now
she so she's ratting harder yeah she's
ratting harder and so Brandon's trial is
as it's coming up nich is maintaining
she thinks Brendan's not as autistic
like everybody says he is she's saying
he's currently in jail about to get his
GED but people depict him like he can't
think for himself his mother paints a
picture of him like he's incapable of
putting his socks on interesting but she
doesn't see it that way because he also
you know there's also situations where
he's been almost threatening this in the
past yeah so it's almost like a when
this happened it was like a thing that
came to fruition that everyone always
knew that this could happened yeah it
wasn't like a they probably need to get
like a third party evaluator to see if
he how bad his autism really is yeah
that's why she's saying it can't be if
he's about to get his GED I don't know
if that's a fair way to weigh it but
she's basically saying saying she wants
him to get the maximum punishment which
now that he's 18 I think they want to
try him as an adult even though it
happened when he was 17 they want to
give him 30 years as a Max probably
won't be that but she's she's advocating
for that like give him the maximum and
then the activists and along with his
mother are saying free
him so those are two very different
results of this I would say if the mom
wants to free them then [__] send
them back home to the moms so the moms
get beat up you deal with them yeah the
reason they put him in the group home is
because he started acting out more and
with her husband at home with like heart
issues she didn't want to like push that
cuz you can't be like not my problem and
then someone else solve it you know it's
like hey get that problem out of there
then okay cool then you take care of the
problem so the mother blames like
explicitly says she blames the district
and not him she thinks it's a District's
fault because they didn't handle his
curriculum correctly where he's not
supposed to have you mean after she
pwned him off to a group home cuz she
couldn't take care of him yeah see
that's the tough part bro I'm I'm
actually with the mom here snitches get
stitches double down on it and sh
there's no way this guy was in like
wrong you [__] up people that snitch on
you luckily we're not of hive mind so I
actually think question like usually
when somebody gets [__] up and then
this is a whole like Court thing often
times there's like potential money on
the table for the person who got [__]
up yeah I'm assuming in this situ
situation though it's not like the chick
who got like concussions and broken ribs
and [__] is going to get any type of
paid off right unless she sues the
school or the district it sounds like a
criminal case though you know what I'm
saying she probably there's probably no
money there to pay her out even if she
did do a civil suit which means it would
make sense for her to be like if I'm not
going to get money punish the [__] out
of this guy it's not like he's an heir
of a fortune that she can like there's
I'm not saying right and wrong here I'm
seeing practicality from her voice it's
like damn she's not going to get
anything but the the most gangster viral
ass whooping broken ribs and definite
trauma of course she's going to say
maximum she might not be able to walk
again or she might have lost bodily
function she says that her speech is
slow uh she just has really slow
cognitive functions now and is
struggling and which honestly when you
see the video you wouldn't be surprised
somebody and she and she not young
either she's going to fight for maximum
punish I don't think she's in the wrong
for that a 57y old lady getting brain
trauma like that wait she's 57 you can't
bro that's hard to come back from bro so
I'm okay I'm I'm but I'm not saying he
deserves 30 years of Maximum I'm just
saying she definitely has the right to
fight for the maximum punishment okay
that's fair to imagine your mom getting
stomped out by a kid dude that's [__]
crazy and also like the the because he's
so big and strong like this kid is
dangerous yo oh you're going to say he
looks like Caitlyn Jenner huh what were
you going to say yeah what were you
going to
say you're not
wrong remember I told you guys about
that one kid that at the tutoring center
I used to work at yeah that kind of
reminds me of that kid cuz that kid was
15 and he was like 200 something PBS and
he was a big ass [__] already
and he would just come into the torine
center sit in the corner put his head
down and he was a parachute kid so like
his parents paid the tutoring center to
just kind of be like the after school
and kind of take care of them and so
they do have a curriculum but then he
has a very [__] you [__] everyone like
I'm I'm pissed all the time mentality
yeah and so he'd be in the corner I'm
not even in charge of him and he'll be
like just sitting there and then Any
teacher that even like came up and like
hey excuse me can you want to do
whatever he would just start swinging
and [__] like this [__] is crazy
yeah and then like but he was the
teacher was probably getting paid big
bucks to handle handle himself so that's
when she was like hey like can you start
being his like teacher and I was like
what do you want me to teach him what
yeah he was like can you like can you
start like just mentoring him like give
him something I was like what can I
teach him like honestly how to miss
anything to punch he's like you could
teach them anything and I was like oh
[__] okay and that's why I started
teaching them like how to fight I was
like like we were like first I just
started like going to his house um cuz
they don't want him at the tutoring
center she's like I'll pay you double so
that you don't have to come in but then
you go to their house wow so I show up
at his house and then he's just like
standing there and then his mom would as
soon as I come his mom okay he's yours
and the mom would bounce too see that's
a funny sign there's your sign so we
just started I I just took it easy I was
like Hey Le want to like just go for a
walk and he's just like
and then I was like hey you want to
learn how to how to fight and then he
was like yeah I was oh [__] let me let
me see what you got and I would like
throw out my hand and he would start
like punching and I was like oh [__] we
started having Rapport and in the
between like taking breaks we would talk
and I think like a kid like that was
just so much anger that was like the
only way I can get to even establishing
any Bridge so that when we brought him
back into the classroom like in class I
think I was the only teacher at that
school like hey what's up man and he'll
like like that versus every other
teacher would like hey how's it going he
wouldn't even like turn or look at you
like he was just ready to just [__]
sock someone in the face he was so
[__] pissed I don't know if he was
Autistic or not but he was just with
that classify his autistic at all I
don't even know I don't know what this
fool had he ate pizza every day cuz I
think he liked Pizza didn't want to eat
anything else so it's Mom would go to
his kitchen would F be stack of pizzas
just
like literally at like large pizza every
[__] day it was where do you think
his anger stem from you think it's from
his parents maybe his dad's not there
Mom wants to bounce and then the [__]
little brother is like the softest guy
in the world probably because he's
scared of his big brother that could
flip on any it was like a crazy situ
that sounds s similar and he lived in a
giant mansion in Pasadena it was like
one of those where like um when I go to
his house I can hear the echo of his
German Shepherd like it was at the back
of a Double Tree
I'm like dude that was that took 5
minutes after I rang the doorbell for
the dog to reach me the back of a double
yeah that was [__] crazy dude I'm
like damn this is a balling ass house
but the most empty home I've ever been
in damn your parenting is hard huh nah
it's still
easy but I mean this situation is just
different I mean like from the start she
adopted a kid who already had issues
yeah and then honestly it looked like at
towards the end it was beyond her
ability on how to help him yeah yeah I
agree with Bart like there probably
needs to be some sort of like third
party you know person that comes in to
actually see where his mental capacity
is because that is hard to judge like
you know but if he is like very there
and capable then it's like dude he
[__] her up they did here's the crazy
then it's criminal yeah right right
before I think this is a strong uh
component to this I think like a year
before he was in his public school they
did put put him in some specialized
autistic like school or hospital and
then they discharged him they were like
you're good kind of thing cuz he
probably bet a teacher backwards yeah D
I folded the doctor cuz then then again
like if we're if we're not blaming the
kids so much yet and we're trying to
think about like the system or the
environment like that's also another
like faulty place that you got to look
into that that's school and then
obviously the mom too or the group home
or whatever you know what I mean so it's
like but then there's a lot of [__]
errors that happen I feel like kids get
misdiagnosed a
lot how many programs does it take to
fail this kid until you're like this kid
can't be helped anymore and that's why
she's like protect the rest of us and
just leave him in jail but the mom is
like if you put this kid in jail for
even any amount of years it's basically
going to be a life sentence then you
protect them you know me you that needs
to be your problem yeah but she knows
she can't I think it just sounds like
weird he needed a man in the house like
if his dad's like you need four men in
this house yeah that man needs to be 6 s
and 280 lb you know you need an MMA
quartet yeah [__] you need a Samoan dad
is what it is oh I sentenced you to
Samoan dad cuz this he's like a Samoan
kid size so he needs a Samoan dad that's
true to be like yeah or send them to
Samoa and then they're like oh look at
this little guy yeah yeah come here bud
how far how far gone do you think a kid
like this is do you think he has any
hope based on what you know about the
world and how [__] turns out damn
um any chance you think maybe a slim
chance like someone like Bart helping
out that kid yeah hey that's not my
problem but but honestly that's that's
what like that's what it might take it
might take someone to be like yo I'm
going to I'm dedicated to be helping you
whatever how easy is that to not very
easy that's what they say about a lot of
the social problems is that it takes a
one toone effort but it's impossible to
get and the consequences you got to talk
about that like when the principal of
the the after school academy assigned me
I was like yeah I'm down to go there and
it's like double pay that's pretty cool
I'm like but if he socks me I'm going
sock him
back I'm just telling you right now if
this one socks me I'm going sock him
back damn so that's all you have to be
like realistic with the expectations too
seriously do you feel a little like this
is kind of
where I feel like in like using so like
let's say he's super attached to his
Nintendo switch I think trying to
repurpose that as a form of incentive
knowing how how easily he can be
triggered by the removal or the even
[__] with it at all that feels like
it was the wrong choice to let him have
anything yeah maybe cuz if his response
is
violent that feels a little codly like
oh like here you can don't kill us
here's your game cuz then think about
what's going to set them off next they
could be like oh we're having [__]
pizza for lunch again godamn it beat
somebody up or how how is he going to
assimilate into society in a future
sense you know what I mean like this
might take like a PhD level [__]
psychologist to be able to work with
this kid I don't know I don't know what
the answer is [__] Phil Jackson yeah
yeah no honestly part of the team or
something you might need you might need
to put this kid into something where
like he needed a Chinese mom and a
Samoan dad oo that's a good strong combo
yep and nted you can't be adopted from a
white family old white lady can't can't
deal with especially with a dad that has
heart problems yeah yeah yeah I think
and a Robin Williams therapist but it is
true though like I think having a strong
male figure in the house is super
important for like boys oh yeah that's
that's all given for sure Bo bro boys
need a fear [__] I feel like they need
to fear their or else they turn out not
fearless and they [__] up adults yeah
they beat up women and [__] like you
know I think that's a thing I think
that's that's the crazy part in his mind
it was like not oh this is even a lady
he's like yeah it was and she was
unconscious after like yeah it was just
straight up enemy kill you and then and
it was over something like you know wait
she adopted him at like 1 years old
before one I think so she's like if he
if he had a hard life right you are a
part of the [__] hard life too po cuz
look we have to we have to take this
into account some parents are just not
good parents yeah some people are just
don't know how to raise a kid yeah you
the and then how complex it is to raise
a kid
that's adopted that's a different race
than you y bro good [__] luck that's
hard she white no the kid black you see
okay you see that okay I think that's a
I think that's a factor I think that's a
factor blame the mom I kind of am well
dude she has to have a little blame no a
little blame if she had him since she
was one you're right like but she was
doing okay so on the upside even though
you know she didn't fix his issues she
did keep him kind of contained from nus
society by wanting to homeschool him and
it wasn't until until the group home put
him in a high SCH but who knows what
happened from age 1 to to [__] 11 or
I guess the question is that's a lot of
time for things to mess up homeschool
kids are weird already the question is
Imagine no seriously if these signs
showed early on when he was smaller if
that could have been treated corrected
it was yeah you know what I mean like he
had by the time he's 6 feet it's like
damn dude it's kind of but that's also
according to the mom right right right
so that's also like we can't take her
word 100% we can't take anyone
especially when she's fully blaming this
the district exactly anybody who's like
look I had a hard time doing it and
stuff like that if she's like not fully
blame pointing the finger then it's
easier to not point the finger too much
at her cuz I'll say this I think for
typically speaking this is massive
generalization I think parents that take
the responsibility and blame on
themselves are probably more equipped to
be able to be a better parent than ones
that are like you it's you it's you it's
oh yeah because they change up their
parenting to adapt how they [__] up
being a parent is a big [__]
responsibility and if you're not that
type of person that could fill those
shoes then you know sometimes it's safe
to say that like yeah you probably
shouldn't be a parent it is hard because
if you end up with a kid like this
that's hard mode 100% you're going
straight to hard you're going straight
to the [__] end dude you're final
boss right here they didn't put that kid
in the NFL or something yeah that's you
tell me you didn't put this kid in
football fing right before the last play
they're taking away his switch go yeah
yeah yeah go smash that guy and he [__]
the coach up and like Oh wrong wrong
team wrong team but honestly if this kid
had an outlet for his aggression that
could be may it may not be the best
thing in the world would you suggest
MMA maybe not I don't know about MMA bro
a lot of violent boys though I think
they get an outlet a lot of violent boys
get a lot lot outlet with martial arts
and all that and you get humbled dude
cuz you get [__] up maybe it'll help a
little bit yeah there are people his
size that could deliver equal or
stronger Force then I think it also
keeps your own powers in check yeah and
if you go getting stupid street fights
and whatever you go back they find out
they're like what the [__] was that you
know
like maybe it'll help I don't know what
the answer is I think I think iido will
help